you guys um
you guys are both vegan correct uh vegan
pescatarian yeah
i watched the interview you guys with my
homegirl ashley where you guys are she
said you guys were vegan
i don't think that's true we'll probably
ate some vegan food oh
you guys are pescataria are you you're
pescetarian are you pescetarian that i
mean i respect that i like fish
hey man i like when i'm out of the
country i i eat some meat you know
whatever i know it's raised right kill
right right out here it's [ __ ] up it's
pink slime
yo if you watch the video of like like
any videos of like how they make like
hamburger meat it'll make you like
never want to eat burger in america i am
american like
five years easily easily have y'all ever
seen a video how to make chicken nuggets
nah look at that it's over on the
internet you don't it's gonna it'll [ __ ]
you up
they just put everything in and just
grind it ground it up they basically
take so they get a bunch of baby chicks
they flip them like this if you're
female you go somewhere to go be
you start making eggs they raise you up
fan you up if you mail they put them in
like this huge bin
and turn the blender on alive chicks
baby chicks bro
and that's chicken nuggets then whatever
and now i know that's everybody's
chicken nugget but that's at least some
of that comes out to be some nuggets
damn yeah i couldn't give up that i
think if i had if i could ever
get to that point i could i could never
give up fish though yeah fish is rocking
sushi lobsters crab i mean you know
those are those